네, 안녕하세요. 오늘은 건축물
대장에 대해서 얘기해 볼 건데 아마
생소하실 수도 있습니다. 건축물
대장을 안 떼 보신 분들이
대부분이고이 건축물 대장은 보통 이제
계약날 많이 보실 거예요. 계약날
봐서 이게 뭐지 하고 막 이렇게 보실
거 같은데이 일단은 말씀드리면 건축물
대장은 반드시 건물 매입하기 전에나
상가 매입하기 전에 출력을 해서 봐야
됩니다. 그래서 오늘은 이걸 왜
출력해서 봐야 되는지를 여러분들한테
좀 설명을 [음악] 드릴게요. 일단
건축물 대장은 민원 24에서 출력을
할 수 있고 보시면 이렇게 나옵니다.
건축물 대장에서 봐야 될 것 중에
하나가 소유자 현황을 좀 보는데
소유자 현황에서 여러분들 이게
있어요.이 건축물 대장 소유자랑
그다음에 등기 사항 전무에서 등기의
소유자가 다른 경우도 있거든요. 그런
경우에는 등기상 소유자가 우선합니다.
그래서 이게 만약에 다른 경우에는
등기상 소유자가 맞아요. 그래서 이게
아마 변경이 [음악] 안 된 거예요.
그리고 반대로이 건축물 대장 면적이랑
등기 면적이랑 또 다르게 되면 그거
같은 경우에는 건축물 대장
>> [음악]
>> 면적이 우선합니다. 그래서 면적은
건축물 대장이 우선한다라고 보시면 될
거 같아요. 그리고 면적을 중요하게
보셔야 돼요. 그래서 여기 보시면은
대지 면적이 나와 있거든요. 그래서
대지 면적이랑 토지 대장의 [음악]
대지 면적이 다를 수도 있어요. 그게
왜 다르냐면 뭐 전제를 받거나
아니면은 도로로 내준 땅들이 꽤
많거든요. 이거 모르고 계약하시는
분들이 [음악] 꽤 많습니다. 돼지
면적뿐만 아니라 그 층마다 면적을
확인해야 돼요. 그래서 보통은 그
1조건 사선을 받으면 3층 이상부터
이렇게 꺾이는 건물들이 많거든요.
그래서 4층이 [음악] 면적이 좀 더
줄어들고 5층은 더 줄어들고 근데
실제로 가서 보면은 4, 5층도
똑같은 건물들이 되게 많아요. 그래서
불법으로 되게 증축해 [음악] 놓은
건물들이 상당히 많습니다. 그러다
보니까이 면적을 확인을 해야 돼요.
그래서 위에서 [음악] 이렇게 좀
줄어든 부분이 없나 이렇게 확인을
해야 되는 부분이 있고 방건물 같은
경우는 이렇게 상단에 노란색 글씨로
써 있습니다. [음악] 근데 적발이
안 된 건물들이 상당히 많아요.
그리고 또 용도를 확인해야 돼요.
근린 생생활 시설 용도로 돼 있는데
이렇게 불법으로 원룸으로 쪼개는
건물들도 상당히 많습니다. 용도가
다를 경우에는 그 사업자 등록증이 안
나올 수도 있습니다. 그래서이
빌딩뿐만 아니라 뭐 상가 같은
경우에도이 반드시 [음악] 건축물
대장을 출력해서 보셔야 돼요. 그리고
이제 건물에 들어가는 임차인 분들도이
위반 건축물이나 용도 때문에 임대차
계약을 하고 나서 막 파괴하는 경우도
있거든요. 그래서 미리 확인을 한
다음에 꼭 봐야 될 그런 서류 중에
하나입니다. 그리고 건폐율이나
용적률까지도 확인을 해서 지금 법정
용적률 법정 건폐율이 맞는지도 확인을
하셔야 되고 그리고 또 확인을 하셔야
될게 주차 대수입니다. 주차 대수.
주차수에 [음악]
예를 들어서 여기 다섯대 돼 있는데
실제로 가서 보니까 주차 하나도 못
되는 건물들도 많아요. 상권이 좋은
경우에는 특히 그래서이 건물에
주차장이 몇 대고 구액이 어디로
나눠져 있고 [음악] 실제로 쓰고
있는지를 한번 확인해 봐야 됩니다.
이거를 떼야지 확인할 수 있어요.
근데 아까 말씀드렸다시피 이거를 보통
다 계약날 보기 때문에 뭐가 뭔지
하나도 모릅니다. 그리고 또 보셔야
될게 이건 좀 미세한 거긴 한데 건축
착공일이나 허가일 그다음에 사용
승인일을 보시면은 또 [음악] 좋은게
이게 되게 진짜 막 몇 달 만에
지어진 과물들도 많아요. 부실
공사처럼. 그래서 이것도 보면은
건물을 거의 한 6개월 만에 지은
거예요. 그래서 이거 엄청 빨리
지었죠. 그리고 만약에 이렇게
지나가다가 어 나 저것을 너무 마음에
드는데 하면은 여기 건축 설계했던
업체 명이 써 있습니다. 그래서
여기를 찾아 가지고 그 회사에 전화해
가지고 설계를 맡길 수도 [음악]
있어요. 그리고 여기 맨 뒷장 보면은
변동 사항이 있습니다. 뭐 위반
건축물 적발됐던 내역들도 있고 대수선
이제 리모델링 [음악] 했을 경우에는
요런 내역들이 여기 다 담겨
있습니다. 네. 그래서 여러분들 그
건축물 대장은 반드시 계약 전에
검토할 때 미리 떼서 이런 내역들을
확인을 하셔야 [음악] 돼요. 자,
앞서 설명드렸지만 면적, 용도, 주차
대수, 그다음에 변동상 등 이런
부분을 확인을 해야지이 [음악]
건물에 된 내용들을 다 담겨져 있기
때문에 이걸 확인하는 것이 되게
중요하다라고 생각을 합니다. 네.
그래서 제가 일단은 좀 건축물
대장에서 얘기를 했는데 [음악] 또
추가적으로 궁금한 거 있으시면
언제든지 댓글 남겨 주시면 제가 다음
주제로 좀 사용을 하도록 하고요.
그리고 여러분들 좋아요 구독은 채널을
운영하는데 있어서 많은 힘이 되니까
많이 눌러 주시고 구독도 [음악] 해
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 오늘 영상
여기까지 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.